the US government is targeting what it
calls one of the world's most
sophisticated international cybercrime
operations prosecutors announced cyber
hacking in bank fraud charges against
two Russians yesterday as Jeff Vij's
reports investigators say that these men
stole from at least 300 different
organizations in 43 countries over the
past decade each and every one of these
computer intrusions was effectively a
cyber enabled bank robbery government
accounts a brazen acts of online theft
matched the alleged criminals lavish
lifestyle on full display in Moscow one
of the accused hackers a scene here
seeming to dare investigators to come
after him driving an expensive sports
car that prosecutors say he paid for
with his victims money these cyber
criminals allegedly stole tens of
millions of dollars from unwitting
members of our business nonprofit
governmental and religious communities
according to the ten-count indictment
Yahoo bets known as aqua and igor tor
chevre operated a hacking group through
phishing techniques and they were able
to install malware on computers from
abroad to steal personal and financial
information the methodology was similar
each time in fact the business computer
obtained bank account numbers and
security codes among the US targets a
school district in western Pennsylvania
and an assisted living facility run by
nuns outside Chicago will these victims
ever get their money back that is our
aim is to follow the money wherever we
can how successful we're able to be in
that time will tell it is very hard do
you stop malicious actors abroad who are
trying to trick us and giving up our
banking information CBS News contributor
and wired editor-in-chief Nick Thompson
says the coders sophistication makes it
extremely difficult to stop them and
that the US should be concerned about
similar attacks going forward the truth
is even if these guys are arrested even
if they stop other people are gonna take
their place for CBS this morning Jeff
the gaze Washington